The general good experience.
I'm here with Peter Joseph,
future king of the world,
future core leader for
the zeitgeists movement.
You're uncomfortable with that,
right?
Growing up to
listen.
You can accept that kings or wells
for just you on the front of the ship,
just like they didn't have to Capria
king in the world playing right there was
an awesome conversation,
man.
It's really,
you're an interesting dude and you've
had a very strange sort of jumped into
this thing.
It's been a ride and you're very
young guy to be doing this too.
You're only 32 years old.
That's amazing.
I would've thought you
were much older than that.
Just really young looking like
if that a lot telling you,
man of the CIA is going to
probably come to you soon.
They're going to try to either make
you more of their own or kill you.
They can put me out of my misery.
You're gonna have to make a decision,
make a decision or use your powers of
charisma to convince them to let you run
shit.
That's what I would suggest work
that ag a little sigh off on the CIA.
What do you think,
Brian?
I think he can do it.
I think I could do it.
It was just the most fucked
damn podcast we've ever done.
I bet.
How many chances have you done the
podcast is in this setting of zero.
This is the first pocket.
I do lots of little radio shows
that you could call podcasts,
but nothing like this.
So
out of the ordinary.
It was so scary as well.
That is true too,
right?
Like there's no goddamn humor to
be a 32 year old dude out there,
you know,
doom and gloom and doom to civilization.
Trying to be positive,
positive.
It's not all doom and gloom,
but I appreciate the flexibility
of different angles going on.
It's fun,
right?
You can actually be yourself,
you know,
and I,
I appreciate the way that you accepted
that and it didn't take yourself too
serious.
That just jumped in and went with it.
So people need to find you.
They can go to the zeitgeists
movement.com and a Tz m moot movement,
Tz movement and the Twitter
and the films were at the site.
Guys can movie.com don't go to watch like
guys moving.com cause that's like some
scam side.
It's going to put a fellowship of Shit.
Shit,
I fucked up.
Bleep that out.
Right.
I thank you for you to
Joseph to Care Prof.
Ours fear.
I had nothing.
I don't know what's up.
What time is shrimp fest this year?
Is it going to be June again?
Late June,
early July.
He got to wait till the
kids are at a school.
That's important.
Yeah.
You don't want kids.
Truman on there.
My finals week.
How do you know who's done everywhere?
Research.
Yeah.
What did you do it last time?
It was June though.
No,
22 20th schools got out like the public
schools got out before that a couple
weeks before that so
it was going to be mad.
People are like,
I'm out of school yet.
I was like that's a great point.
That's a great point.
Yeah.
He got a contract and final TD
do three days of shooting fast.
That's what he did.
He was a weekend.
It was Sunday or Saturday.
Sunday.
Monday.
You can do them at any
time during the weekend.
And then I go to one day
but I like three days off.
Two or three days.
Cause sometimes people can't do it
but they want to be able to catch on.
Oh yeah.
Just calling something Earth Day.
It makes people conscious.
Hell they have
not littering and,
and you know it's doing on Christmas,
Christmas,
that's got to be warm enough
to go around and shit.
People have families and stuff.
It's hard keeping away from
mushrooms on Christmas though.
You can't,
you're more than what happens if
you follow the whole Christmas.
Santa Claus is a mushroom thing.
People are like,
I want to make another thing.
When you look at all the
different correlations,
like when you looked online,
there's stuff I want to say.
How old was those?
Um,
those paintings are,
yeah,
I want to say to,
some of them were not old.
Some of them obviously are new,
but there's a bunch of really old ones
that were looking or where it comes from.
Yeah.
Like something to do with that.
With the Pagan holiday.
They took over like a,
but they were that where the worship that
probably had something to do with it,
but it was also something to do
with just the Siberian Shamans,
you know,
the whole idea was,
and then he comes from the North
Pole pole while Siberia is like,
you know,
near the North Pole and the Siberian
shamans are the ones where they know known
to use this Aminay to
miscarry and mushroom.
That's what we were talking
about with the reindeer too.
I forgot to say that when people
come out of their huts to pee,
when they're having these mushrooms,
timelines reindeers we'll knock
them over to get their pis.
They'll knock them over to get smaller
disagrees with that being a theory
because he said in Siberia there's no,
they don't have that,
um,
that the um,
images and stuff,
they don't have that
of the flying reindeer.
So it was all based on that.
They should have it too.
It makes sense maybe.
But you know,
maybe
maybe to that which is
also possible that to them,
the idea of the intoxicated,
like it didn't need to
have the reindeer fly.
Everybody kind of knew the
reindeer were tripping balls off.
Who knows?
You know,
and then maybe people heard about it at
the reindeer do eat these psychedelic
mushrooms that is a part of their diet.
They actually liked them was pretty wild.
Right out.
We know some psych of dogs kill
animals like DMT kill sheep.
Really?
Yeah.
If they find the graph that's
rich in certain DMT die,
the,
the sheep will eat it and then fall on
their back and their little legs kick up
in the air and they
fucking seizure to death.
Which is pretty good because
the paintings from first.
Yeah.
I wonder.
Yeah,
cows don't ever,
each rooms they have a good relationship
with dogs eating shrooms the other day.
I don't know.
You better be careful man.
Poisonous mushrooms on
the back of my yard.
All these white mushrooms grow.
There's some fucking seriously
poisonous mushrooms man.
And there's some that looked
like suck it delicate ones.
Yeah.
Dogs can eat.
I don't,
shit,
I wouldn't worry about the dog.
I had to worry about you or something
like big mushroom like shit that's not
poisonous and I just throw it over the
fence like they already had enough.
If it is your dad do.
The friend of mine,
a friend of mine got
the most ridiculous dog.
It's a baby shit too.
And all my God,
it's so little man.
It's like this big red day.
No it's a baby cause shit's
who's only grow like that day.
But this is like a little tiny
baby one and like holy Shit.
So cute.
Oh,
Cabo is a should say to
this thing is so cute.
It's ridiculous.
It's a,
it's you.
You can't,
you can't believe it's real.
It looks like a little,
the whole that's moving around,
you know?
Yeah.
They used to be a wolf.
How crazy is that?
What the shits it.
Oh and genetically somewhere about your
job and the way we're doing it to a,
it's the way of breeding out.
It's pretty much what
the Holocaust was like.
Part of that was like a
scrubber to the negative traits.
They won't be part of our site anymore.
They were doing it.
The people that just go all over and they
said the reason the crime went in New
York went,
plummeted,
um,
recently at the hardest
cause of education,
stuff like that.
It's like no,
it's because abortion was
legalized 18 years ago.
That's the only thing.
It can be traced to all the poor people.
Instead of having these kids
and like making new criminals,
they got rid of them so it plummeted 18
years later when they would have been
started being tried as adults.
Oh my God.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
and they were doing it.
It gets people's wills and like North
Carolina that are people sterilizing
though like the super white trash.
Gotcha.
This will be like you're,
you don't need anymore to
just like some amazing,
yeah.
That's amazing.
Wow.
Yeah.
They want to make now it's because
of the education programs like Nope,
you can't trace it back to anything else,
but that,
that's,
and nobody wants to talk about it.
Where did you get this from?
Is all of my friend Kurt
Metzger turned me on to it,
but it's all out there
and all over the Internet.
Cool.
Why?
I'll have to read that.
That's,
if that is a true statistic.
That's fascinating.
That's amazing.
I wish I knew what the years
where it's like the year,
uh,
abortion was legalized
and then 18 years later,
that's so crazy.
Who would have ever thought
and it's like allow fucking,
yeah.
Immigrants or whatever it is or they're
fucking criminals allowed them to get
rid of babies.
Jesus Christ.
I don't want to think like this.
Are you really?
It's just like dogs.
That's
freaking me out here buddy.
It is kind of like dog breeding.
Yeah.
They don't know how the fuck
they ever did that either,
by the way.
They don't,
they only guessing how the fuck
they made all these different dogs.
No one has the direct records,
you know?
No one knows how the fuck
they were mad at shit too.
And I made all wolf and
turn it into a Shitzu.
You can,
you could give me paperwork all you want.
You know,
no one really knows how to fuck.
But he did that.
That's silly shit.
The fuck.
How did they make bulldogs?
Dobermans?
It's all from wolves.
Who,
yeah.
How many generations did that tag?
How the fuck did they
exactly go about doing that?
I think do that from wold,
but I'd have to be over
like a billion years.
I don't know man.
Who the fuck knows they,
you know,
they had said that it was a really
recent discovery that it was a,
it was all wolves.
They used to think that it was a bunch of,
that.
Most dogs are a bunch of
different wild candidates,
you know,
I think that's the word for it.
Kane needs Caney just broke off.
And so they thought there was a
bunch of different wild kind of dogs,
you know,
like jackals or whatever.
And they're all mixed together.
But now it's all wolf.
Man could happen fast.
Yeah,
knows.
But it's from,
it happened because the people,
it's really nuts because
the only thing that,
it's like people,
his dogs,
dogs,
the only thing that's like people where
we're totally not uniform as a species,
but that we can interbreed
with each other.
Oh,
you can in a breed with ones that
don't look at anything like that.
Salmon can't breathe with a bass.
They swim in the same water,
but they can't fuck each other.
Shouldn't be able to breed with the Smith.
What does a Kaplan should have
gone with something like green.
Yeah.
That's fascinating.
Shit,
isn't it?
You know,
people are,
we vary as much as dogs do.
I mean,
you have like many mean,
then you have Shaquille O'neil,
you know you'd have,
they both could get someone pregnant.
You know [inaudible] you've got little
tiny dudes fight 135 pounds and then
you've got dudes like Brock Lesnar who
has to cut weight to make to 65 that's
like a different breed.
Yeah.
It's like this weird like dogs.
We're like dogs in our,
our,
you know how much we vary.
I think this is the reason if you get
like when this race and race traits,
hmm.
Yeah.
Because they keep integrating
the same way over and over again.
What's fascinating that
people still to this day,
it's so clear that people who developed
and certain parts of the world,
it just looked different.
They have different attributes,
they have different strengths
and different weaknesses,
you know,
and you know there's certain
parts of the world where there's,
this is,
here's where the agents come from.
They come from Asia.
Look,
they all look the same
the other way around.
Boom.
This is where the Africans come from.
Look through the ones that live in
Africa was coming near the creditor.
Yeah,
right.
You know,
and the,
that's the argument also that
human beings are some sort of a,
an experiment from aliens
is that we're just like,
like people manipulated dogs created,
they started us off that
they manipulated the DNA.
Yeah.
Just like we manipulated
the DNA of the dogs.
What do you think about that?
True.
Otherwise and not smash and
breeding off for pleasure.
Yes.
That's the end of this video.
Thank you very much.
Follow Ari Shaffir on Twitter.
It's a r I.
S h.
A.
F.
I.
R.
Halacha boy.
Yeah.
Are we filming Steve or no,
thanks for coming on man.
Man That was a lot of fun.
I'm a convert to your program.
Are you beautiful?
I'd like it even more if I wasn't on it.
I think you converted a lot of people.
I think he changed a lot of people's
opinions on hunting and trapping and I
think you expressed yourself in a way,
um,
in the podcast it's like,
you know,
we were talking about where it's such
a long form you get to really express
yourself.
You could kind of tell like sometimes
like you had some really well thought out
answers to these questions almost like
he had been waiting for people to ask
them because this is like something
that's really kind of bugging you about
perceptions.
I think the same issues come
up again and again and I think,
you know,
you put them to me in a way that was
actually more challenging to me because I
could tell you were like
coming to honest conclusions.
I mean you're asking like real questions
that came up and not questions that you
learned somewhere.
I'm going to ask him that
because that was a good point.
Like you're,
you're like giving me thoughts
that popped out in your mind.
It's a huge subject.
And I know that I wound up doing a lot
of like adding layers on things like
this.
But then if you look,
there's also this and it makes
that not so this national,
but it's really hard
to come in and be like,
no,
this is wrong and this is right and
it's wrong and this is right cause it's,
things are so complicated the same way
that it's hard to come in and say that,
you know,
it's hard to come in and start
talking about euthanasia and accurate.
You have all these like definite
absolute opinions about the subject.
The wolf was really protect them.
There's so many different versions of,
you know,
like,
uh,
scare sites where people are
terrified of these wolves.
He's,
well,
there's so much bigger and that's the
way you broke it down made so much sense.
Well they have the more smart food and
the food's not ready for them and they
get bigger.
Was saying even after all of this,
I still can't certify we speak
to that issue because I just,
I don't know,
I guess coming from a lifelong,
a lifelong path as an outdoorsman,
she just not like an uneducated opinion,
not devoted a good permanent,
it's like trying to study
and understand these issues,
but that is something I
frankly hadn't heard of,
but my guests,
I think that if you
follow what I'm saying,
that path would maybe lead you
do some enlightenment about that.
If you could live in a
part of this country,
if you could like pick any spot in this
country where you would have like gray
hunting and great fishing and a good
place to like live off the land.
What part of the country would you peg?
I
did best,
um,
and,
and kind of enjoyed that aspect of
my life the most when I was living in
Montana.
Really?
Yeah.
Why Montana?
Well,
you know,
it's like 77% public land.
You have very generous,
uh,
good long seasons.
The haunt,
you have a wide variety.
You can haul almost all north
American big game there.
Um,
I liked it.
I said,
I still have family there.
I went there multiple times a year.
This is a great place.
Also.
Also Grizzlies.
Yeah,
but there's no season on mills,
but you can just shoot them
all year round or you know,
right now you cannot,
right now you cannot hunt.
There's still under protection.
If I see a Grizzly,
I'm shooting that you will wind
up being in tons of trouble.
Find stealthy.
I'm like,
man,
Joe,
they had guys check this out.
I'm fucking put landmines
around my property.
They've had guys,
you had guys that have killed,
they've had a black very permit,
so they're legally hunting blackbird
and accidentally kill a grizzly and you
wind up having your hunting privileges
revoked and in all states to cooperate in
this agreement for period seven years,
$10,000 fine.
Damn.
Some big deal.
You don't,
you don't,
you don't mess the grizzly bears is
there some place they can hunt grizzlies,
right?
Where's that?
When we say the only state right now
where there's legal hunting of grizzly
bears or brown bears
in and much of Canada,
are grizzly bears the same thing?
Yeah,
there are.
They're not recognized as
being subspecies anymore.
They recognized as being the same thing.
They used to call myself spaces.
They've been back and forth on
brown bear was like so sweet.
And Jeremy is the one no like and general
Noman like in general like Yo popular
terminology.
Popular Terminology would be that people
refer generally to the ones in the
interior as grizzlies cause they,
again,
there's like morphological differences.
The ones in the coastal
areas with access to salmon,
good,
much bigger.
They have a different appearance.
They generally refer to
those as brown bears.
Brown bears are actually
larger than the intercoastal.
The coastal bears get much bigger.
Had the potential of getting much
bigger in the bear is not interior.
The interior.
The Grizzlies.
Yeah.
So people usually call those grizzlies.
That's interesting.
Coastal one's brown bears,
but they're all part of the same species.
They're not recognized
as subspecies anymore.
It's same species versus herbalists I
think is what it totally embarrassed of
the really scary motherfuckers.
Right.
That's a whole different,
that's a whole different species.
But they now realize something they
hadn't realized before that there is some
genetic exchange between polar bears
and grizzlies and some people argue that
they can have viable offspring.
I don't know if that's true.
I don't know if that's
too common for hybrid.
That's not uncommon by someone I think.
I don't know the answer to that,
but I know that there's,
there's a question about whether
they can have viable offspring.
However,
as a motherfucker and some people think
that what's driving that exchange is
that as we're losing ice polarized camps,
it's pushing more polar bear activity on
the mainland where they're running into
and hanging out in the grizzly bears.
That's just something
that people throw off.
I don't know if that's true or not.
Have you ever counted a
polar bear in the wild?
I've never laid eyes on a poor rental.
While it's one of the,
it's a,
it's one of the few,
I think it might be one of
the only large North America.
I think it is it the only,
I think it's the only large
North American mammal.
I have not seen the wild.
Wow.
It was a polar bear or the common,
I mean can you go look for him and
you'd have to go to certain spots?
It's very reliable to go
see them in certain areas.
Like on Hudson Bay there's places
where you very reliably find them.
In the winter there's places where you
will go and check them out and they you
can like book a tour or
trip and go check them out.
I just haven't seen most frightening
stories I've ever heard was some some boat
crash somewhere and these guys got off
on an ice shelf and a polar bear started
getting closer and closer to him and
jumped in the water and climbed up on the
ice shell just fucking killed the Nate,
one of the guys in front of his friends.
You have toward that to
me felt like kill people.
No,
they do.
I think.
I think that probably in a per capita
sense like deaths attributed the death per
number of bear ratio is probably
highest with polar bears.
They fucked people up,
man.
Definitely second most high
with with the grizzly bears,
which means a scratch people up.
I would like to get mildly
scratched up by a grizzly bear.
I would like to have,
no,
I want to have,
I would like to have,
I would like to have one five claws scars
where I would like to start
wearing my shirt open all the time.
You should shoot a grizzly
bear and then have a friend ty,
the par to a stick just for decoration.
So Helen,
yeah.
Listen man.
It was an awesome conversation.
Thank you very much.
If you ever want to come back again,
please do anytime you're in town
and we could do this 10 times,
I guarantee.
Guarantee you.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Hey everybody.
We're here with Hamilton Morris
and his buddy Matt the camera man.
Man,
we don't need to know your last name,
right?
No,
that's all right.
Whatever man.
Matt was there the whole time.
We had a podcast looming
over our shoulders making it
very uncomfortable because
there was one person in a
room that didn't fucking talk.
So I tried to say Matt said,
hell,
once you become a part of this.
But no,
it's just dedicated to his creepy
filming you and not talking strategy.
I'm glad I had the Imac in front of me
so I didn't have to see how this man,
how come you didn't just hang out with us?
Why wouldn't you just put the
camera now for a little bit?
He's a professional.
Is that what it is?
You're not allowed to test.
Suppose it's my job.
You're not the person ambitious to hear
me talking to on the day cause they
just,
Oh,
I understand.
It would been cool if we
got you in there though.
Matt,
we're going to put you on this.
Okay.
We're on.
What is this?
This is um,
we do a little video blog where
we just put little clips of uh,
people that just did the podcast,
you know,
ask them if they had fun.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's just one more piece of
content that people enjoy.
Yeah.
God,
I can post podcast wrap
up sort of the thing.
I know it seems ridiculous,
but they love it.
Right?
I mean what was good?
We're just neutral moon,
so here it is.
The next one with you and what we were
saying before we did this was one of the
coolest things about the Internet is
that you could watch somebody stuff like,
and you know,
I was like,
oh,
this guy,
he's fucking crazy.
What is he doing?
He's hanging out doing all these drugs
and having a good fucking down to meet
that guy and then boom,
we're doing a podcast killer.
Amazing,
right?
Yeah.
It is strange fucking world.
We live in
science.
It's craziness.
It's probably witchcraft.
We should have a show
would be the odd couple.
I'll come in and fuck it everyday
I see ghosts and you're like,
listen,
it's a blurry picture.
Like,
dude,
my aunt died and this building
and to this day no ghost at all.
I don't believe in any of that.
They'll believe that it's maybe like
what's the most rational argument that
someone had was that an experience can
be so traumatic that so much energy is,
is released in the form
of emotions and fear,
but it actually stains in area or
that you can go near that area and
occasionally and get a little flashback.
Steven Cain shining idea and people
hallucinate all the time for various
reasons.
Too Smart for horror movies.
I love horror movies
because I would think you'd be in
there going werewolves are impossible.
Perhaps not fit him.
How's it pants working now?
No,
no.
I seen every horror
movie out there almost.
And it doesn't make you,
uh,
you don't,
you have to,
you know,
sit there and
look at some ridiculous shit.
No,
I think it's scary.
I'm scared.
What are you scared of?
Slasher films like that con?
No,
we can supernatural ones.
I mean,
you know,
yeah,
kind of.
I haven't watched,
I used to watch them all at the time,
like every day really.
And then I started to wonder if it
was damaging my mind in some way.
Really.
Yeah.
So you think that would
be more than a hundred DMT
crazy asshole.
Well,
you know crazy.
I have to be to be 24 and I've
already done DMT 30 days in a row.
That's something like someone like
cancer does when they're like 90 like,
well fuck it.
Let's see what happens.
I don't have to worry about it anymore.
Let's just,
red line is pitch and see what kind of,
you know,
it's just kind of performance.
We can get out of it.
You did it.
How old were you when you did it?
Reason,
I don't know.
19 probably about 21 but yeah,
I don't think that's especially damaging,
but inundating your subconscious with
all of these violent images daily seems
like it could.
I don't know.
Do you ever worry that someone that's
going to see all this shit that you put
online and that you are going to be some
sort of a target for antidrug activists
prove a point.
I mean there's people that
are really hate drugs.
It's possible.
I'd be more afraid that it's
just like academic opportunities,
job interviews,
things like that that you
got to be missing out on.
For sure.
Listen,
you don't need that.
Just write books,
write books.
He used the internet done.
You can do whatever the fuck you
want and you've got the Internet man.
I mean,
it's beautiful to be able to get,
you know,
some sort of a job teaching at
some prestigious university.
That'd be amazing.
But you know,
it also would be amazing.
You just fucking putting out books,
put out books,
keep putting out videos,
keep fucking doing what
you're doing now you're,
you're doing some cool shit.
Yeah.
Well I'd like to do both if possible.
Is it,
is it a deterrent or is it,
you know,
somehow or another business?
I didn't know it must really excessive,
but there's plenty of people in that good
prestigious university positions that
have had sort of histories
of one kind or another.
So it's not,
it's not like,
it's not like getting a job at a
major bank or something like that.
There's also a lot of fear.
There's a lot of paranoia.
I know people at Mit that
have prescriptions for
Adderall and things like that,
and they were terrified that anyone
would ever find out that they take
prescription stimulants.
What is the deal with Adderall?
Is it that I have a friend
who's on that shit every day.
It just seems to me like
that seems like a weird mood.
It seems like an energy pill.
Oh yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
So was that someone
should be taken every day.
We'll,
it is a
complicated word,
but I think that certain people
benefit from taking a daily,
this dude looks like he's aging rapidly.
It's possible.
I mean,
it may accelerate your metabolism
in some way that you think,
right?
I Dunno.
It's hard to say.
I think that if you're taking something
that's on my massive of stimuli and then
look at those faces of math,
right.
Well I think though,
you don't look that bad.
That's hilarious.
That is hilarious.
He,
Heidi Fleiss the airport,
Yardi sobriety,
and then look better after the neck.
It's like,
it's not as if they were extremely
attractive people to begin with.
And then I hated math.
Maybe a jacket [inaudible] character.
So I kind of check.
You remember picking up in a bar,
you know it's just a mistake.
Dropped a mistake.
It's just the perfect end to the weirdest
interviews ever in the history of the
podcast.
Hamilton Morris,
you're a hell of a guy and it was
very awesome having you on the show.
Really interesting stuff that you,
you really most most
informed on socket dogs,
especially if any guy I don't think
we ever talked to so it was cool.
It's cool.
I think a lot of people
got a lot out of that man.
Awesome.
Hope again.
Weird you out too much.
Hi everybody.
What's happening?
Beautiful people.
Joe Diaz here.
We just finished a great fucking podcast.
Thank you for listening.
We had a good time.
I can't believe you still told some
stories that I hadn't heard before,
which was like a bunch of them.
The fucking roofing.
I never heard the story about
you roofing in Colorado.
Same Gray ball and yeah,
the gray mouse store
and there's another one.
I haven't heard of it before.
It's always something we always
have a good fucking time though.
The Aspen.
It sounds like a fucking trip.
It wasn't true.
I still today
that's a kind of a fucked up
place where Charlie Sheen that is,
that's her child.
Mueller held that bitch down.
Yeah.
Is it a coke a?
It's,
it's a place where people with means
go and park camp potty and you know the
cops Kona it's going to be okay.
He doesn't make it to aspen.
Protect their own.
Brian.
So let me ask you,
what's it like?
That's quad has reached
its great temporarily
in with the big boys.
It's cool.
Yeah.
Well if you do it once,
you can continue to keep doing it.
A lot of work though,
like you're constantly,
it's paying off and it's funny
how these guys leave that.
That's called a million.
Well I fuck your pawn password for that.
That's where it makes sense.
I mean if you think about it,
we have to get
regulations strengthened.
Fucking numbers and numbers are power.
Wealth,
ladies and gentlemen.
Thanks for two next weekend,
Chicago.
And then by the time this video's out,
it'd be a year ago.
We have a Chicago theater date and a
couple of days and we're getting fired up
for this video.
I'll be off of Vegas.
Go to fucking Vegas.
Vegas.
February.
Third House of Blues.
You savages stand black.
Stay black and a fall.
Joey Diaz on Twitter.
It's mad flavor.
Red Band.
Are we fee feed Minneapolis?
All that shit.
See you see you
right here.
Here we are.
Powerful.
C Two l shell for c two o
but it is lifted,
right?
I heard you can shoot it up.
Yeah you can.
It's like a thing that he did and like
the fucking Vietnam War substituted for
Ivy and the South Pacific.
Not Crazy.
Just go running to your veins like water.
Like when you get a drip.
Yup.
It's like an Ivy Tripp,
coconut water,
coffee enemas.
I've heard of a lot of different things.
What does that do?
Is they give you a crazy buzz?
I thought it was just really good for you.
Healthy,
but why is it healthy?
I think the caffeine,
I don't know.
Just cleans out the inside.
What about that woman who did a DMT enema?
That's that girl Hamilton Morrison.
Oh by the way,
for any of this saw the
Hamilton Morris interview,
we fucked up.
We're so sorry.
We got Hamilton way too high.
We got way too high.
We just completely over modulated.
Sometimes when you go to these
dispensaries you forget like when you buy
something,
whether it's an indycar or
a sativa you forget and uh,
there was definitely
a sativa or excuse me,
definitely an Indycar,
which is like the stuff that makes you
sleep here and it was way too strong.
We were all off the tracks and into
the woods and we were trying to keep a
conversation together,
but we were just ball.
Here's an artist's
rendering of it right here.
Yeah,
exactly.
It was real.
It was preposterous.
The fact that we pulled together
any sort of a podcast was amazing.
He kept fucking with his
boys who would get it.
Like really?
Dude,
he was so high.
He was like playing with his voice
and that was freaking me out.
I love that dude though.
How I love anybody who's out
there doing wild shit like that.
I love anybody who's out there just
fully embracing the free culture.
And you know,
pushing forward and he did a really
cool thing with the isolation tank
manufacturers.
He went down there and film
there and he took an ad,
a ball before he got in.
I said,
just take some like an hour and a half
before you go on it and be perfect.
It just get in there and ride
it and that's exactly he did,
he said was amazing.
I went for a three hour ride.
Wow.
It's super high on a pot
Brownie and an isolation tank.
I get one of that.
That's what you and I got to do next,
dude.
You and I and the Onnit guys,
we're going to start
opening up tank centers.
I had a conversation today,
I was doing this interview for our
Vegas show next week and I'm doing this
interview and I'm like,
you know,
talking about the woman asks
me about isolation and I said,
yeah,
I
go,
they're really hard to find.
You know,
there's a few places in California,
but I know that used to be a place
in Vegas and I thought about,
I'm like,
why are they hard to find?
Why?
Just to start making tanks that great.
Yeah.
There's fucking tanning centers.
Math,
you think they couldn't be tank centers.
And by the way,
those tanks,
here's what a great way
to meet cool people.
You know,
go with a bunch of other people that are,
want to explore their consciousness.
A bunch of other people that
want to relax and float.
A bunch of other people that are
curious about those sort of things.
That'd be like a great place if
you have like a big waiting area.
And it was like really quiet and
couches and shit and magazines.
People would probably hang
out there after there.
Yes,
you could have little shows there.
You could have authors come
in and talk about books,
you know,
books on consciousness.
You could have psychedelic that guys
like Dennis mechanic come and speak.
You know,
let's do it too.
And we should do that.
Right.
And I'd see the birth of an idea.
This is totally what
the next stage we'll do.
That's how I'm gonna move my friend Tommy
junior from Connecticut to having to
come down and run our,
our tank centers.
And yeah,
we need to fucking figure out a way to
make ourselves completely self sustaining
outside of the mechanism of Hollywood.
It's totally do I have an idea,
but I'm not going to say on the air.
Powerful,
powerful,
powerful time limits on power for
led Lazarus and your dog's name.
Blanche Blanche.
Eliza is one of those crazy dog ladies
that brings her dog everywhere she goes,
wouldn't it?
Comedy clubs and she brings her
dog to the icehouse chronicles.
The darn just fucking wanders out
around the streets of Pasadena.
We had to go running after
it while she was on stage.
That's snuck out.
Yeah.
No.
When he was watching her,
nobody.
You left her there and
nobody was watching her.
She didn't know why you weren't there.
She went looking for you.
Why don't you just leave her in your
car when you do stuff like that?
It's not hot out.
I'm the only car for a sec.
Someone steals your car.
Okay.
I guess you could look at it that way.
If someone's a glass
half empty sort of get,
I wasn't cheap
back then.
You could make book bags.
You can keep her inside the perfect
messenger.
You're probably the most aggressive
female comedian we know what's,
what's the secret to that?
Yeah.
What's that about?
You're very
just doing the video.
What's the sea?
Yeah,
you're fucking on stage.
The audience came to have a good time,
but I give it to him.
None of us.
I do mind like that.
Right?
Do you get upset when you see people?
What else?
And they're like flip through their notes.
It was like 12 people in the crowd
and you're working something out.
Okay.
But I just feel like an
audience came there drunk.
It's a Saturday night.
They worked hard all week.
They want to cry from laughing and that's,
and I have a lot of energy.
I like to move around and
wouldn't give it to him proper.
Yeah,
I hear Ya am aggressive but got to get
well.
It's good.
You have a great personality.
It's not,
it's not a bad thing.
It's just unusual.
You're not unusual girl.
You have a lot of lesbian qualities,
but you're no less than drove a blazer.
I told you that.
Is that good?
Did it have a bass on the back?
It,
nobody had a
splash decal on the side and my
parents told me that I picked that one.
I don't know,
recollection of that.
Pick the splashing out of
all the Chevy's in the lawn.
I was like,
oh,
at the splash.
Do you Kent?
Thanks team.
Did you have like a roll
cigarettes in your sleeve?
No,
but I do have a,
a pen Sean first leads without the
shirts or shirts with the sleeves rather
get out and sleeves.
Isn't it fucked up when
you do something like that?
You reverse something and you
have no idea you did it never.
It's like what?
I didn't make a big deal.
Well not only that,
like you know that you don't even know
what the fuck happened and I believe you
made a mistake like that cause
you know I was articulate.
I know,
but then they'll call you back the tape.
That's the problem.
Like the podcasts or see myself say
something on the podcast like one time I
said,
yeah,
it's like,
it's like pcs versus a windows,
which is the opposite.
It's
like they get the jest and they correct.
Correct.
Do you know the difference
actually along that,
what am I,
what I hate is when you go
to give someone directions,
you're like,
it's right up here on that road.
They're like,
you made over here and like from inside
a building or like who has spatial
relations that much on the
30th floor,
one or
none of that
fucking assholes.
Just be nice to Eliza.
Who's a good person?
Why do you make dudes uncomfortable?
We think that's all up.
No,
it's not my problem
meeting with me.
If I make you uncomfortable,
let me know.
He'd make me a little unclear.
No,
I've seen,
you know,
that's not what I said.
No.
Uh,
I don't.
No,
but there's,
there's no men are intimidated
by intelligent women.
First of all,
men are,
a lot of men don't want
the game to be difficult.
It's already difficult to
get a girl like you and to,
you have to measure up to a
girl as well as other men.
You know?
Like that's why from the get go,
I'm like,
you don't have to be smarter.
Funny.
As long as you're really hot.
So you just like have guys
that are just nice to you guys.
The guys smarter invited him.
He hasn't have to be hot.
That's okay too,
but you have to somewhere
you gotta be better than me.
So you could be not funny or smart but
hot or or be funny and smart and not so
hot.
Those are the two I was
funny and smart can be hot.
I see what you're saying.
So you're just like a guy and a lot of
ways like guys don't like most guys don't
need grocery that's foreign or
that they are going to be around.
Well someone said this and I would
always attributed to George Harrison,
although I can't find it
online or they said it,
but I'm pretty sure he did say he
said all I need from a woman is to be
attracted to her.
Everything else I get from him,
man,
that's really,
I remember much more current that going,
God,
that's so brilliant.
Women are much more complex
and some of them for sure,
some of them,
some of
what's interpreters,
we need so many like yeah,
you need a guy to be hot,
but then it's like,
but he has to understand me
and listen and not do that as,
and it has to be 75 degrees and I
want to fund restaurant and wedges.
Like
no,
I'm very low maintenance,
super low maintenance,
super specific about what you want.
It's,
it's demanding and like a cute way.
Like you would never get annoyed.
Okay.
Are you sure you're not
an asshole about it?
Yeah,
it was.
It comes time to food then it has to,
has to be your why.
So like if you don't care really I think,
what do you like that like you
have arguments with any man about,
it's not about way,
it's why I don't want to eat in the car.
The guy and he's,
I'm like,
I'm hungry.
He's like,
you want to go?
Or where do you want to go eat?
And I'm anything he says I don't want,
I don't want to get barbecue in
the middle at noon on a Tuesday.
I just woke up in the middle of the day.
I'm going to get a heavy
and I'll get coffee.
You ever need to talk to her?
Hughley Walkleys in Van Nuys.
So cool.
So
I do,
I like me,
but at the dinner,
but a dinner,
I just woke up maybe like
some of the lighter gender.
You're a carnivore.
I like the Tourist Korea's,
oh,
the Brazilian restaurants.
[inaudible] Japanese Bahrein and I'm
eating fucking almost every one of them.
Even the faithfulness.
We ate it in Chicago.
Fuck.
The child's are awesome.
And the Japanese,
when you can make your own,
they have guy who Kako Laci.
And I got so fucking Shit,
man.
Man.
I'm talking to good food or analyze.
Uh,
what else do you know?
Jesus had bad breath.
No,
it smells good.
I thought like someone gets a barbecue.
Sweetie.
What else?
Uh,
do you have to tell these
fine people are one thing.
What else they need to know about you?
Just follow me on Twitter.
You'll find out every fall and it's crazy.
But,
and she's very funny.
Very talented.
Yeah.
The TV show,
which is actual show show and a real one,
it's called excused.
And you can go to excuse to tv.com to
check the local listings in your area.
But in la it's on weeknights
at 12:30 AM on k cal,
mine,
Bam.
So there you go.
You done been told and you
can follow her on Twitter.
I L I Z a.
And here's what you do,
the dual doggy.
So too,
we just got done up beautiful podcast
with my friend Brian Count and my friend
Jimmy Burke and you're crying
and gentlemen is a life changer.
And I'm doing this,
uh,
what is this thing called?
Turbo Sonic.
I'm doing a turbo sonic,
which is sound waves that
go through your body.
And I've actually never
had this sensation.
It's a really weird feeling right now.
And I can hear my voice.
I actually can't control it.
That's how I'm talking the sound.
This is a giant speaker and it's sonic
waves that are forcing his body to
vibrate and keep an eye on because right
now this is like the high frequency end
of it,
but then it gets to this both studying
frequency like their and totally surface.
Now you hear it,
it,
it varies.
There's like a whole,
you can do it manual and you can
have it set to a certain level.
It's not just being chickens,
it's
actually sonic waves.
So when you say you're being shaken,
you sort of odd,
but it's not like so much shaking.
You sonic waves through your whole body
MNA through your fucking feet from a
speaker and the Russian scientists
with users when they're in space,
use this to stay up in orbit far longer
than anybody thought was possible.
Yeah,
it stimulates.
You might have said something similar as
your body's ability to produce you with
growth hormone.
It's great for you.
It's fantastic for their muscle density.
Yeah,
yeah.
It,
oh yeah.
It's amazing.
It's unbelievable.
All of the whole time I've been
having here for some reason.
It's how you saved my life.
When I got that girl pregnant and
I was going to marry her and you,
he literally started to flip out.
You don't want to lose it,
dude.
I used to host.
It protects you.
I protected him from so many girls.
There was so many times
he was with a girl.
I was like,
what the fuck are you more?
I would have saved a lot of times when
you got into before your your lovely
wife,
you've got into a lot of a hose situations
where you were saving a lot of fucked
up girls like you've,
you've,
you ran across a lot of lost
children and even when the rest of,
and I don't want to go with a good family,
I want to go with the track marks
in the bat tattooed on her face.
Please.
That sounds like a tragic,
yeah,
there was a,
there was a quite a few
situations where I was like,
what?
What are you doing man?
What the fuck are you doing?
Patty was the only one.
Patty actually called
me up and thanked me.
She goes,
the only one that talks
everybody else was like,
Oh man,
I guess you're having a baby flipped out.
I was like,
you're having a baby with her,
like you can't do this.
Flipped out.
He literally started to,
I was screaming at him because I saw him
convincing himself that it was going to
be okay.
I go,
dude,
you do not want to enter into any sort
of situation with this girl for the rest
of your life.
I go visit out of your hands.
You can't control it.
That's fine.
I'll go,
but you do not want a
longterm relationship with
this crazy bitch when you can
avoid him.
Please do these crazy well.
Life is crazy,
dude.
And you know,
as we develop,
we realized that we are a,
a bunch of deficits that we have when
we're younger and we're still trying to
make up for shaking like a leaf.
It's not even the machine.
This is how I'm thinking about his past.
That's what it is.
Crazy,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Isn't it awesome that feels,
it makes you feel great and it feels
stimulated when you get off of the ads.
And it's also exactly what Christopher
and Mcdonald's in his book.
And what's that book,
Bubba?
The,
uh,
the running book born to run.
It's an awesome book.
You have to read.
Oh,
I'd love to.
What does that,
no,
no number on it.
This guy,
because this was for big
kind of Lanky Irish guy,
I love to run in his late forties,
he heard about this tower who more a
tribe in Mexico that were running ultra
marathons,
a hundred miles in a day.
And no,
not bare feet.
They were taking down tires,
cutting them down,
melting them,
and they just having the smallest bit
of rubber on the bottom of their feet.
They just conformed for their feet.
So basically it was like they were running
barefoot because they're going over
rocks and boulders and cactus
and 400 miles in the desert.
So they melted down times and had
to get them to stick to their fear.
They just,
uh,
they took twine and they just took
leather title and meet up there.
Any primitive sandal.
Now I wear these.
That's kind of what they did.
They took a very,
there's no heel because your feet or
telling y'all the first thing and then
usually the only thing that's touching
the ground when you're walking and so of
course it's affecting your nervous system,
your feet,
or telling you what to do.
You're free sending right
now as I'm moving around,
my feet are sending off and be just my
brain [inaudible] behind those Vibram
five fingers.
She,
where did we go for?
I know what else I do.
I lift weights barefoot.
Absolutely.
Me Too.
I wouldn't buy items.
I don't where I don't go
buy from Steve Maxwell.
I got that from Tim Ferriss's book.
God,
I got to like Steal Maxwell.
He had me doing everything barefoot.
Kettlebells barefoot.
Yeah,
because you can lift more and you
feel it through your toes too.
You feel better?
Yes.
Your nervous system is becoming,
being gay with the more we have heels,
the more we have shit on
the bottom of our feet.
The more insulated we are from the world,
that when someone created a running shoe,
what they did is they created
it so that when you land,
you land on your heel,
puts this pounding on unique.
Once you're supposed to lay out your toes,
that's how people are supposed to run.
You're supposed to write your chosen.
It's a shock of exactly.
That takes all the
pressure off your knees.
So fighters now they do sprints and do
sprints for those five finger tow things
and they run on grass and everyone,
you know it's a completely
different way to train is change.
Revolutionize like chick training and
nutrition has taken on a revolutionary
step.
Like,
like the way guys train.
How like the intensity
of the short intensity.
It's completely different.
Yeah,
completely there button.
If he is still John's so runs five miles
swims an hour and a half guys twice.
Freak freak,
freak,
turbo.
Sonic.
Ladies and gentlemen,
check it out.
If you find a place where you can
float lab in Venice,
they have them at the float lab in Venice.
I stop it.
Just press stop.
Okay.
Just give it one second.
Let it completely die off
and she know ran up there.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Brian Cowen,
you can get Brian counts podcast.
It's the Brian Count show and it's
available only on the desk squad labor on
Itunes,
which is also the home of
the ice house chronicles,
that's ice house Ice House chronicles,
which is one of my favorite podcasts
called the Bryan County sheriff because I
was like,
what do I name it?
Something cool and he's like,
Scott,
you want to make sure
that they know your name.
Your name should be the
like someone's like,
you know like Dunkin is like,
I got to call it the
lavender hour or you go,
no one's going to remember that
called the Duncan Trussell show.
He's like,
you're right now his new thing
as the Dunkin trials with Joe,
because he had called
the donkey tries to show,
but he was calling it the lavender Aga.
You're missing 50% of the people
that are doing on your podcasts.
It'll leave it at least what the fuck
is going to look for the lavender hour
man.
But what does that even mean?
What does that even mean?
Weird.
I love your Dunkin.
That's the end of this podcast,
video blog.
Brian Reichle.
Anything else to say to these fine folks?
That's all I got to the desk where I.
Dot TV.
[inaudible] dot com bye [inaudible].
Beyond that,
what are you guys friends?
We're cool.
We're cool on the line.
You really loved it
when you first met her,
right?
No,
no,
because suddenly of the books,
I sold it.
Thanks buddy.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
there was too much of us at the,
at the end.
It was a disaster.
We were all drunk,
but it was still a lighthearted.
Those a lot of fun.
Yeah,
we pulled it off.
We know we were talking over
each other when we were hammered,
but you know,
that's what happens when the camera.
Thanks man know.
I really appreciate it.
I appreciate you next year.
Yeah,
for sure.
Definitely same time next year.
Yeah.